welcome to this video playing hard or
hard or from Israel no I played him two
times already one win one draw no
remember I don't remember anything about
those games ok just to game so let's see
an Italian game but I'm going to play
with Bishop e7 this is often a bit a bit
more interesting then when the Bishop c5
setups ok i have my special idea with f5
it's that very often leads to quite
quite nice play
yeah okay the night needs to go
somewhere not so clear where exactly to
h 2 r2d2 92 looks normal but it really
clocks up his development quite
considerably maybe nitey one isn't that
bad maybe nights e2 e3 later okay take
take this first d5 was also possible but
maybe is playing at five you know never
know okay um d 593 should be 65 might
might come down let's just develop this
I didn't expect yeah not quite sure but
I don't want to retreat the night
somewhere this is not a great structure
but I of course have some considerable
space advantage on the King side so
Queenie a g6 with this sacking idea of
Bishop d7 I'm going to go with Queenie 8
queen eh g6 also rook da derp sometimes
possible so over to g6 which should
induce a king move right the tech t5
here so that it's difficult for him to
keep the pawn I don't only like that
ready okay um how do you get at the king
here
maybe maybe with Bashar c5 first not
sure I need rooks am for this attack a
bishops if I be mighty Queen III this is
not leading to do anything Jonny unsure
how to do that I move the night maybe I
can move the night over to g5 oh it's
not clear what this this is really doing
age 594 okay hey Sam try to get more
pressure on your form
going to prevent before yeah this looks
quite good for white I think maybe night
be 1c three could be an idea McKay is
playing that not playing as playing well
I think looks looks very sensible okay
you know it's tough to really threaten
something here maybe here night h5 or
something itself it's tough ok we will
retreat here then try to capture this
and not even it's not even just trying
he will probably manage
that's not very nice
I thought that f3 might be still an
option but you can really just take with
the Queen that's very very annoying
yeah just a pawn down you with a not
very very good position Bishop c3 it's
not really a brilliant threat or
anything but I don't really see what I
should do now I lost how far too much
time then maybe the structure where the
double porn was was too shaky I don't
know nice somehow it didn't get any
attack going
not sure about this c700 what or maybe
night to deform if I'm the deficient
can even play I don't know it's just a
bad position it's not much not much to
find him time morning yeah maybe allow
this this night coming to to do to e6
it's bad anyway in many ways it can also
just take g6 and everything else fails
yeah the a drug hangs so it's very much
possible that there are some tactics 95
may be coming
yeah what can I do we just totally
totally I'll play me him I have no moves
this time not directly checkmated check
check maybe I am
yes I don't see a maid but check check
check check check black forfeits on time
yeah it was a was a win in in any case
yeah that wasn't good rename yeah I
don't know d5l I really don't know this
is a good move even but after this it
seems that the the better Wyatt
structure still seems to still seems to
be worth something I didn't really get
any King side attack going it's a bit
tough tough to see what should i do
should i really really retreat the light
I me I can do that it's not a big
problem just go to be aid I don't know
now this really shouldn't be too bad
maybe maybe the the real problem is
around here up to this point I don't
think black is in terrible shape I ever
have pretty active pieces okay the
computer gives you six as a clear edge
for black yeah there should be something
to make it playable at least I mean I
wasn't really expecting to have an
advantage if the computer is right here
but yeah this is a fairly logical move
why didn't that do this actually it
opens up it opens up the default and
this is really nice and all the rookies
active my structure is terrible but I
have have active pieces very active
pieces Mia this looks very good actually
looks like this in the mix this is a
line given by my stock fish shop g4 yeah
this kind of stuff can can happen black
now is very active yeah something like
this is a flat win you like cannot a
right cannot avoid the Queen age 5 h to
stop there should play c6 the thing is
what I overlooked is I only saw this
later it's night-night b12 c3i here
Bishop g4 is winning okay upgrade yeah
just there just a bad game I just played
a very bad game here yeah only now I saw
might be one and this is basically
deadly he would just win you for and I
don't have any any plane just just
fishing here but it's lost yes many ways
to win what he chose was just one of
them okay thanks for watching